allora dovete dovete sapere che
io sono nato di sette mesi settimino e
quando sono nato mi ricoverarono
immediatamente all'ospedale di modena
sono nato in un piccolo paese della
dell'emilia e dopo che riuscirono a
salvarmi l'incubatrice così via
il medico disse con mia mamma c'è un
problema suo figlio vuole continuare a
dormire perché crede ancora di essere
nella pancia della mamma
allora questo vecchio questo questo
anziano medico diceva che problema c'è
gli diamo della caffeina e mi fecero due
mesi di flebo di caffeina appena nato a
voi fa ridere ma come potete immaginare
io lo sono venuto a scoprire
all'università col primo caffè preso con
gli amici perché la prima mi ero accorto
che mentre le mie sorelle prendevano il
caffè latte alla mattina me dicevano
prendi la frutta prende un succo di
frutta però poi all'università prendo
prima tazzina di caffè e rimango sveglio
per quattro giorni cosa che era anche
utile quando si faceva un esame è una
cosa che adesso mi crea tantissimo
imbarazzo io vengo molto al sud e
nessuno crede a questo fatto che io sia
allergico al caffè per cui tutti andiamo
a prendere un caffè no faccio sempre
delle figure mi faccio dei nemici dei
nemici ovunque ma in realtà è un
problema
la caffeina mi ha dato però una modo di
lavorare e di e di scrivere anche molto
particolare vi vorrei parlare di un tipo
di memoria che finora non ne abbiamo
parlato ed è un po correlato a questo
che vi sto dicendo io a causa della
caffeina in corpo ad esempio ho
pubblicato molti libri ma non rileggo
mai i libri dopo che sono vigne i libri
dopo che sono pubblicati parto subito
con un nuovo lavoro e ho deciso di
occuparmi di diritto delle nuove
tecnologie che le nuove frontiere la
criminalità informatica le
investigazioni quindi ho un'idea di
memoria un po differente da quella vista
finora che però vi vorrei spiegare
che cosa succede succede che audrey
hepburn dichiarava spesso ai giornalisti
una frase che è diventata celebre lei
diceva di averla sentita da qualcuno non
si ricordava da chi la frase era questa
il segreto di una vita felice è una
salute di ferro e una memoria corta e
lei ha impostato questa idea della
memoria corta noi prima abbiamo sentito
parlare in questa sala della memoria
come ricordo della necessità di
ricordare io vorrei dirvi una cosa e
fidatevi i più grandi problemi giuridici
del prossimo futuro soprattutto con le
tecnologie saranno date dalla memoria
corta dal diritto per ciascuno di
dimenticare e non di ricordare audrey
hepburn aveva avuto un'adolescenza
incredibile ve la racconto brevemente
lei era figlia di un inglese un agente
un agente assicurativo che sposa una
nobildonna olandese e lei ha vissuto
l'adolescenza in olanda è nata a
bruxelles ma poi andò in olanda proprio
quando i nazisti invasero i paesi bassi
e quindi lei soffrire la carestia
dovette cambiare cognome perché un
cognome inglese figuratevi con i nazisti
che avevano invaso il paese nella sua
biografia scrive che passò un periodo
dove mangiava imovie dei tulipani perché
la carestia un fratello fini nei campi
di concentramento una vita incredibile
perché così era per lei la memoria corta
la memoria corta era il diritto di
dimenticare diritto a dimenticare
diritto di essere dimenticati
il diritto di ricominciare e
ricominciare dopo un tradimento dopo un
lutto dopo una malattia dopo il carcere
quando è importante la memoria corta per
chi va in carcere vuole ricominciare una
vita il diritto di riprendere a vivere
noi giuristi vediamo in questo ambito
più che in quello della memoria lunga
che adesso vedremo il problema
principale che le tecnologie porranno
nei prossimi anni già lo stanno ponendo
lo vedete con i fatti di cronaca i
suicidi l'impossibilità oggi di
rimuovere i dati non credete a chi vi
parla di diritto all'oblio di sentenze
su oggi un dato che finisce nel digitale
tecnicamente impossibile da rimuovere
ritornerà allora come fa uno a a
garantirsi questo lato della memoria che
è altrettanto importante è la se la
memoria stessa il diritto all'oblio e
l'altro lato il novecento lo sapete il
secolo della memoria lunga dopo lo
vedremo perché però qualche studioso io
ho portato nice perché nice dice sempre
cose intelligenti faceva notare beati i
dimentichi c'è beati coloro che riescono
a dimenticare
c'è una un bel racconto di borges del
1944 46 non ricordo bene ha creato
questo personaggio che l'ha chiamato è
il memorioso lo scrittore dice questo
anche vi faccio una proposta ora io vi
do una memoria eterna
e vi ricordate qualsiasi cosa ma al
contempo voi mi date che non riuscite
più a dimenticare nulla
vi ricordate tutto ma non riuscire a
dimenticare un solo episodio borges nel
racconto descrive queste scene
incredibili di questo ragazzo che va a
pranzo e nel piatto dove sta mangiando
la frutta le mele si ricorda tutti i
piatti che ha mangiati in quell'istante
e tutti i cibi e ogni situazione
allora io sono un po del parere che oggi
l'attenzione va non soltanto lo vedremo
nel conservare la memoria grazie al
diritto ma anche nel riportare come
diceva audrey hepburn il diritto di una
memoria corta perché la memoria corta e
correlata alla l'umanità questa è la mia
università all'università di milano
volevo con voi interpretare e fare un
minuto di interpretazione filologica di
una frase che mi ha detto uno studente
al ricevimento giovedì mattina proprio
mentre stavo preparando questa
conferenza è venuto da me a uno studente
ricevimento giovedì mattina e vorrei che
leggiamo insieme la frase mi ha detto
questo sono uno studente frequentante e
lei il professore
allora io ero contento di questo
incontro ha detto cavolo è un bellissimo
esempio da farvi di memoria corta il mio
studente avvenuto a lezione ma non si
ricordava più se fossi io il professore
era giustificato io faccio lezione a 300
studenti o how le grandi
ho scoperto che non è un caso di memoria
corta un tentativo di truffa nel senso
che lui stava cercando di convincermi
che fosse un frequentante per avere una
riduzione per avere una riduzione del
programma
[Musica]
pensate che gli antichi romani avevano
l'istituto bellissimo della dalmazzo
memorie ma terribile era considerata una
delle sanzioni più forti
la dannazione memorie era rimuovere
dalla memoria collettiva
il ricordo di una persona partiva con
l'abolizione minis si eliminava il nome
si rompevano tutte le statue che lo
raffiguravano si ridipingevano i quadri
per gli antichi romani il fatto di non
potere essere ri
mandati ai posteri era al massimo era il
massimo della vergogna siete d'accordo
con me che oggi molto spesso il
contrario quante persone vorrebbero
essere rimosse da internet dai social
network con dati non più attuali ma una
rimozione completa è impossibile oggi la
dannazione per alcuni versi è il
contrario
prima si è parlato vado veloce di una
cosa molto importante avete visto i
comportamenti che mirano a distruggere
ricordo anche dei monumenti
la bellissima palmera leasys l'idea di
distruggere per non ricordare oggi forse
l'istituto della dannazione moria è
rimasto per alcuni versi soltanto in
questo questa prima parte era quella che
secondo me la memoria corta
l'omessa per prima perché secondo me da
giurista è quella che solleverà sta
sulle valli più grandi problemi sono
veramente guai gestirla nell'era
digitale
perché il digitale non consente la
memoria corta la memoria lunga ne
abbiamo già parlato vado veloce e quella
che dopo la seconda guerra mondiale ha
reso chiaro a tutti che cosa poteva fare
e dove poteva arrivare la malvagia e la
cattiveria dell'uomo i comportamenti
genocidi e altro la memoria lunga è
essenziale perché ricordare un segno di
civiltà a tutti i vari musei della
memoria il digitale che è utilissimo per
mantenere questi ricordi a prada c'è un
bellissimo centro che si chiama per il
ricordo dei crimini degli stati
totalitari
sapete che pradé è stata sia sotto il
controllo e il totalitarismo sovietico
sia sotto il nazismo
il digitale sta aiutando tantissimo qui
nessuno discute sono d'accordo con voi
che anche questo sia un punto essenziale
da da mantenere perché ricordare serve a
non commettere gli stessi errori
figurativi sono emiliano
abbiamo una cultura del ricordo vide
volere soltanto una notizia anche qui
c'è qualche problema giuridico certi il
diritto è attento a questa cosa perché
ci sono leggi ancora in discussione oggi
ad esempio sul negazionismo sui cimeli
razzisti nazisti e fascisti in rete
alcuni stati dell'est europa stanno
quando normative che tutelano i simboli
e il divieto di usare certi simboli
quindi non è che il diritto abbia
dimenticato questa parte della memoria
lunga
secondo me a è più interessante la prima
perché un lato della personalità che di
solito è poco esplorato e poi c'è il
gran finale il sogno del mind uploading
di prendere il cervello umano e la
memoria e trasferirla su un computer
ci sono tanti esperimenti oggi che sono
in corso e poi dopo l'apoteosi è la
morte non vi chiedo di fare una catena
neurale ma potete toccarvi anche in
questo caso però ho portato una lapide
che è una lapide spiritosa allora
pensate al problema che sta creando
l'esibizione della morte in rete la bbc
ha annunciato che nel 2065 saranno più i
profili facebook di morti che vivi vi ci
sarà il sorpasso oggi più che noi
abbiamo qualche amico morto negli stati
uniti sta andando moltissimo questa
figura del def manager il becchino
digitale è una persona che magari un
lavoro che consiglierò quel mio studente
della memoria è una professione di chi
gestisce tre o quattro venti cinquanta
account di social network di morti per
conto della dei familiari o di chi vuole
mantenerle la commemorazione allora
pensate la memoria lunga è sfociata
anche oltre la morte
e questo è sta creando tantissimi
problemi
vado molto veloce su che cosa cambia il
digitale che cosa ha cambiato il
digitale nei confronti della memoria
perché lo sapete
alcuni sostengono addirittura che non
dobbiamo più parlare di memoria nel
digitale ma dobbiamo parlare di ricordi
dei ricordi non sono più ricordi diretti
guardate qualche frase che vi ho preso
starebbe bene anche su una maglietta
all'americana cioè oggi facciamo ma non
ricordiamo oggi riprendiamo e
registriamo ma non manteniamo le
sensazioni al ricordo delle sensazioni
oggi viviamo di impulsi e non di ricordi
e duraturi e interessante è l'apoteosi
sono queste foto che vedete dove i
concerti non vengono più vissuti in
prima persona ma vengono vissuti tramite
un filtro una uno schermo qualche
cos'altro
in conclusione come può il diritto
arginare questo quadro come può
intervenire in un quadro così complesso
innanzitutto vi confermo che memoria e
diritto sono strettamente collegati la
memoria è il senso di civiltà di cultura
e di modernità di un popolo
e così lo è il diritto un popolo civile
si capisce anche dal livello del suo
diritto
altra cosa stiamo vivendo un periodo che
sta strattonando tutte le convinzioni
che noi abbiamo da ogni parte e non
sappiamo più come comportarci tra
memoria e terna e dimenticanza tra
diritto all'oblio e idea di mortalità e
quindi vi lascio con tre domande il
diritto riuscirà e sarà capace di dare
la morte delle informazioni sapere che
ci sono persone oggi ti chiedono la
morte dei dati
vogliono che i dati riescano a morire in
rete non rimanere come c'è la morte
biologica la morte organica che ci sia
anche alla morte dei dati riuscirà il
diritto a superare la tecnica e dare
finalmente l'oblio la memoria breve di
audrey hepburn e riuscirà il diritto ad
aiutare a preservare la memoria in senso
positivo
eliminando l'odio ed eliminando tutte le
questioni
tenete sempre presente che è un
conflitto meraviglioso ma che deve
sempre avere al centro l'essere umano
una tecnologia che non si attenta l'uomo
e soprattutto alle persone più deboli
non ha senso vi saluto con una parte
della poesia di primo levi che conoscete
bene
meditate che questo è stato sono le
cinque parole che meglio di ogni altra
possono far comprendere quanto
tecnologia diritto ma soprattutto l'uomo
possano superare questo momento di
grande conflitto che sta confondendo
anche noi esperti noi giuristi
vi ringrazio molto